this is a battery it wasn't even the
full force of typhoon nangka vests
merely its prelude but it was already
deadly the high winds that heralded the
storm caused tornadoes one man in his
forties was killed when his car
overturned east of Tokyo local media
also reported that another person was
killed north of Tokyo in a landslide
this isn't a storm leaving destruction
in this part but before its arrival in
these areas where the special warning
was issued unprecedented levels of rain
are being recorded as the typhoon
approaches we expect even more severe
wind and rain for those in this area
please evacuate immediately in order to
save your life and those dear to you
satellite pictures show the truly
massive scale and why forecasters said
this could be the worst storm to hit
Japan in more than 60 years so they had
prepared flights had been grounded
bullet trains kept in the station and of
course Rugby World Cup matches were
canceled
Scotland's crucial match against Japan
was still scheduled to go ahead on
Sunday and here the host nation showed
their determination to train rain or
shine this very much the former fans who
had no games to watch made a spectacle
of the storm instead
but as the day drew on the typhoon drew
closer it finally made landfall in the
dark and now it was at its peak the
storm is right on top of us now and as
you can see the streets here you know
completely deserted everyone is
bunkering it down in the midst of this
very very powerful storm the wind has
been extremely strong the rain lashing
down it's a bit like taking a bath next
to a jet engine really it's so powerful
after all the preparations that Japan
has made at this point it just has to
bear the brunt of this storm and see
what happens only when the storm has
passed could Japan count its cost for
now it raged on into the night Tom
Cheshire Sky News Tokyo